tenemos la función fx la cual es una
función continua por pedazos observa que
está definida para algunos intervalos
por aquí para cero menor que x menor o
igual que 2 f x es igual al logaritmo
natural de x y para los valores mayores
que 12 para x mayor que 2 f x es igual a
x cuadrada por el logaritmo natural de x
y lo que queremos hacer es encontrar el
límite de fx cuando x tiende a 2 y lo
que es interesante de este límite es que
nos piden el límite en la frontera de
estos dos intervalos así quisiéramos
solamente evaluar efe 2 entonces qué
haríamos en este intervalo de aquí
porque 2 es mayor que 0 10 menor o igual
que 2 entonces
efe de 2 serían poner 2 en este primer
caso y me quedaría el logaritmo natural
de 2 pero
esto no es necesariamente lo que el
límite tiene que ser para saber el
límite tendremos que saber el límite que
se aproxima por la derecha y el límite
que se aproxima por la izquierda ver si
ambos existen y si son iguales
solamente si existen y son iguales
tendremos el límite bien definido
entonces vamos a hacerlo primero
pensemos en el límite de fx cuando x
tiende a 2 por la izquierda por valores
menores que 2 y bueno ese va a ser el
caso en donde vamos a operar en este
intervalo de aquí vamos a trabajar con
valores menores que 2 y nos vamos a
aproximar a 2 por la izquierda bueno
pues este caso es continuo en el
intervalo bajo el cual estamos operando
para valores mayores que 0 y menores o
iguales que 2 para esos valores va a ser
igual a simplemente en evaluar ese valor
en esta función porque es continuo sobre
todo ese intervalo entonces simplemente
será el logaritmo natural de 2
el logaritmo natural de 2 o keith ahora
pensemos en el otro caso pensemos en el
límite de fx cuando x tiende a 2 por la
derecha para valores mayores que 2
entonces el límite de fx cuando x tiende
a 2 por la derecha como lo sacamos bueno
aunque 2 cae en este primer escenario
tan pronto como tomemos cualquier valor
mayor que 2 caemos en este segundo
escenario entonces vamos a estar
aproximándonos a 2
esencialmente usando este segundo caso y
una vez más este caso de aquí es
continuo para toda x no sólo mayores que
2 de hecho para mayores o iguales a 2
pero regresando a este límite podemos
seguir este mismo argumento que acabamos
de mencionar y entonces decir que este
límite va a ser igual a esta función
evaluada en 2 porque una vez más si
vamos a evaluar esta función en 2 nos va
a dar este caso de aquí pero si nos
aproximamos a 2 x
la derecha para valores mayores que 2
entonces estamos tratando con este
segundo caso así que vamos a evaluar en
este segundo caso el valor de 2 porque
sabemos que es continua para valores
mayores iguales que 2 entonces tendremos
2 al cuadrado por el logaritmo natural
de 2 lo cual bueno es 4 veces el
logaritmo natural de 2 y ahora observa
ya podemos ver que el límite por la
derecha existe y también podemos ver que
el límite por la izquierda existe pero
lo que debe de causarte ruido es que
estos dos valores son distintos nos
aproximamos a valores distintos por la
derecha como los que obtuvimos por la
izquierda es decir si quisieras replicar
estos verías un salto en la gráfica
actual tendrías una discontinuidad justo
ahí en el valor de 2 y entonces este
problema en particular donde tenemos una
discontinuidad que es alta nos está
diciendo que este límite que buscábamos
no existe porque el límite cuando
extiende a 2 por la izquierda no es
el límite que tiende a dos por la
derecha entonces podemos concluir que el
límite de fx cuando x 32 no existe